now on the reference sheet and you if
you want you can pull it up right now
there are a bunch of equations I have to
liberally not shown you them yet
unrelated to all of this stuff this
equation here it's not one of them okay
here's why what was it what knowledge
was required to prove this result it's
not a rhetorical question what do we
need to know you need to find the
equation of a line well 2 point formula
that's that's part of the course you
need to know that ok what else do you
need to know we need to know where the
points are but that's part of the
definition of what this is this is
something you expected to know so
therefore this process you actually have
to be able to recreate ok and people
don't necessarily like that welcome to
the extension 1 course ok now that's
nice but so what well let me show you
some nice a really really nice piece of
geometry here ok this is not just any
parabola this is the parabola in a locus
form right with like focal length and
directrix and all that kind of thing ok
speaking of focal length where is the
focus on this parabola where is it one
of the coordinates of the focus if the
focus is like saying here what were
those coordinates B well it's the
x-coordinate C you're right very good
and the y-coordinate would be if it's
the focal length you go up from the
vertex and you go eight units right so
this should be 0 comma egg yeah now
watch what happens some chords go
through the focus some of them I'm
originally these chords are called vocal
chords a focal chord is a chord that
goes through the focus if that thing
goes through there then this really
badly messily drawn coordinates sorry
that's a little more legible those
corners ought to satisfy this equation
do you agree ok so therefore let's sub
that into the equation of court and you
see what happens right into equation of
chord ok 0 comma a it's really really
simple because 0 is just going to make
this term disappear what comes up on the
left hand side
have a look she's gonna be a what's on
the right-hand side this becomes zero
take away what just a peek you okay what
was I gonna do I think we should divide
through by a we can do one more thing
hmm what would P and Q again they're the
parameters of these particular spots
aren't they what is the parameter again
we prove this like 20 minutes ago the
parameter by definition is the gradient
at that point the gradient at that point
is a little Q the Grady at that point is
little pay what does it mean when
gradients are multiplying together to
give negative one they're perpendicular
let me show you what that looks like
yeah we're just exploring can't find
anything but I'm going to show you
something that we just found okay yeah
so don't worry too much about all of my
equations over here on the left-hand
side that's just to make stuff work okay
is that thick I can't remember if I made
a thing for you yeah it's good okay now
have a look at what we've just got here
right seeing this black line going right
the way through I could have been a
little more fancy to restrict it but
that's the cord okay I know it's on line
at the moment just picture it as an
interval okay
here's his our cord and it's going
through the focus here right so can you
see this blue line is the tangent at one
of like that's that's cute
for instance and my orange line is my
tangent at P so can you see where the
tangents me do you see this the right
angle there now watch what happens as we
move I think this is what I want to move
there we go let's slow that down that's
going way too fast let's bring it back
I want to change direction that's what
to do okay so can you see this point
here see this point here that's the
focus right there that's why the chord
no matter where it goes it's always
passing through this focus okay so you
can see these tangents here are always
at right angles right everywhere they go
I'm gonna bring it back into the middle
actually it's gonna come back into the
middle itself there we go these tangents
always meet at right angles okay so
using the equation of the chord and
because we know what the focus is we've
proved this really interesting result
that every focal chord every focal chord
there it is right there
right the ends that make it a focal
chord they have perpendicular gradients
and that's what makes their tangents
perpendicularly okay now this kind of
geometry and the fact that it does this
is why parabolas are so special just
like you remember where did circle
geometry and it's like oh my goodness
look everything that's weird like this
angle is equal to that angle why is that
because circles are special shapes when
you've got you know a diameter and you
look at that angle oh my goodness that
angle is a special angle it's right
angled well you get the same kinds of
things on parabolas because parabolas in
circles believe it or not I made of the
same kind of DNA